[Music]
let's begin this lesson by defining the
term statistics statistics is a
mathematical science pertaining to the
collection presentation analysis and
interpretation of data it's widely used
to understand the complex problems of
the real world and simplify them to make
well-informed decisions several
statistical principles functions and
algorithms can be used to analyze
primary data build a statistical model
and predict the outcomes an analysis of
any situation can be done in two ways
statistical analysis or a non
statistical analysis statistical
analysis is the science of collecting
exploring and presenting large amounts
of data to identify the patterns and
trends statistical analysis is also
called quantitative analysis non
statistical analysis provides generic
information and includes text sound
still images and moving images non
statistical analysis is also called
qualitative analysis although both forms
of analysis provide results statistical
analysis gives more insights and a
clearer picture a feature that makes it
vital for businesses there are two major
categories of statistics descriptive
statistics and inferential statistics
descriptive statistics
helps organize data and focuses on the
main characteristics of the data it
provides a summary of the data
numerically or graphically numerical
measures such as average mode standard
deviation or SD and correlation are used
to describe the features of a data set
suppose you want to study the height of
students in a classroom in the
descriptive statistics you would record
the height of every person in the
classroom and then find out the maximum
height minimum height and average height
of the population inferential statistics
generalizes the larger data set and
applies probability theory to draw a
conclusion it allows you to infer
population parameters based on the
samples to
sistex and to model relationships within
the data modeling allows you to develop
mathematical equations which describe
the interrelationships between two or
more variables consider the same example
of calculating the height of students in
the classroom in inferential statistics
you would categorize height as tall
medium and small and then take only a
small sample from the population to
study the height of students in the
classroom the field of statistics
touches our lives in many ways from the
daily routines in our homes to the
business of making the greatest cities
run the effect of statistics are
everywhere there are various statistical
terms that one should be aware of while
dealing with statistics population
sample variable quantitative variable
qualitative variable discrete variable
continuous variable a population is the
group from which data is to be collected
a sample is a subset of a population
a variable is a feature that is
characteristic of any member of the
population differing in quality or
quantity from another member a variable
differing and quantity is called a
quantitative variable for example the
weight of a person number of people in a
car a variable differing and quality is
called a qualitative variable or
attribute for example color the degree
of damage of a car in an accident a
discrete variable is one which no value
can be assumed between the two given
values for example the number of
children in a family a continuous
variable is one in which any value can
be assumed between the two given values
for example the time taken for a
100-meter run typically there are four
types of statistical measures used to
describe the data they are measures of
frequency measures of central tendency
measures of spread measures of position
let's learn each in detail frequency of
the data indicates the number of times a
particular data value occurs in the
given data set the measures of frequency
are number and percentage central
tendency indicates whether the data
values tend to accumulate in the middle
of the distribution or toward the end
the measures of central tendency are
mean median and mode spread describes
how similar or varied the set of
observed values are for a particular
variable the measures of spread are
standard deviation variance and
quartiles the measure of spread are also
called measures of dispersion position
identifies the exact location of a
particular data value in the given data
set the measures of position are
percentiles quartiles and standard
scores statistical analysis system or
SAS provides a list of procedures to
perform descriptive statistics they are
as follows proc print par contents proc
means proc frequency proc univariate
proc G chart proc box plot
Proc G ply proc print it prints all the
variables in a SAS data set proc
contents it describes the structure of a
data set
proc means it provides data
summarization tools to compute
descriptive statistics for variables
across all observations and within the
groups of observations proc frequency it
produces one way to in wave frequency
and crosstabulation tables frequencies
can also be an output of a SAS data set
proc univariate it goes beyond what proc
means does and is useful in conducting
some basic statistical analyses and
includes high resolution graphical
features proc G chart the G chart
procedure produces six types of charts
block charts horizontal vertical bar
charts pie donut charts and star charts
these charts graphically represent the
value of a statistic calculated for one
or more variables in an input SAS
dataset the trade variables can be
either numeric or character proc box
plot the box plot procedure creates side
by side box and whisker plots of
measurements organized in groups a box
and whisker plot displays the mean
quartiles and the minimum and maximum
observations for a group proc G plot G
plot procedure creates two dimensional
graphs including simple scatter plots
overlay plots in which multiple sets of
data points are displayed on one set of
axis plots against the second vertical
axis bubble plots and logarithmic plots
in this demo you'll learn how to use
descriptive statistics to analyze the
mean from the electronic data set let's
import the electronic data set into the
SAS console in the left plane
right-click the electronic dot xlsx data
set and click import data the code to
import the data generates automatically
copy the code and paste it in the new
window
the proc mean
procedure is used to analyze the mean of
the imported data set the keyword data
identifies the input data set in this
demo the input data set is electronic
the output obtained is shown on the
screen note that the number of
observations mean standard deviation and
maximum and minimum values of the
electronic data set are obtained this
concludes the demo on how to use
descriptive statistics to analyze the
mean from the electronic data set so far
you have learned about descriptive
statistics let's now learn about
inferential statistics hypothesis
testing is an inferential statistical
technique to determine whether there is
enough evidence in a data sample to
infer that a certain condition holds
true for the entire population to
understand the characteristics of the
general population
we take a random sample and analyze the
properties of the sample we then test
whether or not the identified
conclusions correctly represent the
population as a whole the population of
hypothesis testing is to choose between
two competing hypotheses about the value
of a population parameter for example
one hypothesis might claim that the
wages of men and women are equal while
the other might claim that women make
more than men hypothesis testing is
formulated in terms of two hypotheses
null hypothesis which is referred to as
H null alternative hypothesis which is
referred to as h1 the null hypothesis is
assumed to be true unless there is
strong evidence to the contrary the
alternative hypothesis is assumed to be
true when the null hypothesis is proven
false let's understand the null
hypothesis and alternative hypothesis
using a general example null hypothesis
attempts to show that no variation
exists between variables and alternative
hypothesis is any hypothesis other than
the null for example say a
pharmaceutical company has introduced a
medicine in the market for a particular
disease and people have been using it
for a considerable period
of time and it's generally considered
safe if the medicine is proved to be
safe then it is referred to as null
hypothesis to reject null hypothesis we
should prove that the medicine is unsafe
if the null hypothesis is rejected then
the alternative hypothesis is used
before you perform any statistical tests
with variables it's significant to
recognize the nature of the variables
involved based on the nature of the
variables it's classified into four
types they are categorical or nominal
variables ordinal variables interval
variables and ratio variables nominal
variables are ones which have two or
more categories and it's impossible to
order the values examples of nominal
variables include gender and blood group
ordinal variables have values ordered
logically however the relative distance
between two data values is not clear
examples of ordinal variables include
considering the size of a coffee cup
large medium and small and considering
the ratings of a product bad good and
best interval variables are similar to
ordinal variables except that the values
are measured in a way where their
differences are meaningful with an
interval scale equal differences between
scale values do have equal quantitative
meaning for this reason an interval
scale provides more quantitative
information than the ordinal scale the
interval scale does not have a true zero
point a true zero point means that a
value of zero on the scale represents
zero quantity of the construct being
assessed examples of interval variables
include the Fahrenheit scale used to
measure temperature and distance between
two compartments in a Train ratio scales
are similar to interval scales and that
equal differences between scale values
have equal quantitative meaning however
ratio scales also have a true zero point
which give them an additional property
for example the system of inches used
with a common ruler is an example of a
ratio scale there is a true zero point
because zero inches does in fact
indicate a complete
absence of link in this demo you'll
learn how to perform the hypothesis
testing using SAS
in this example let's check against the
length of certain observations from a
random sample the keyword data
identifies the input dataset the input
statement is used to declare the aging
variable and cards to read data into SAS
you
let's perform a t-test to check the null
hypothesis
let's assume that the null hypothesis to
be that the mean days to deliver a
product is six days
so null hypothesis equals six alpha
value is the probability of making an
error which is five percent standard and
hence alpha equals 0.05 the variable
statement names the variable to be used
in the analysis
you
the output is shown on the screen note
that the p-value is greater than the
Alpha value which is 0.05
therefore we fail to reject the null
hypothesis this concludes the demo on
how to perform the hypothesis testing
using SAS let's now learn about
hypothesis testing procedures there are
two types of hypothesis testing
procedures they are parametric tests and
nonparametric tests in statistical
inference or hypothesis testing the
traditional tests such as t-test and
ANOVA are called parametric tests they
depend on the specification of a
probability distribution except for a
set of free parameters in simple words
you can say that if the population
information is known completely by its
parameter then it is called a parametric
test if the population or parameter
information is not known and you are
still required to test the hypothesis of
the population then it's called a
nonparametric test nonparametric tests
do not require any strict distributional
assumptions there are various parametric
tests they are as follows t-test anova
chai squared linear regression let's
understand them in detail t-test a
t-test determines if two sets of data
are significantly different from each
other the t-test is used in the
following situations to test if the mean
is significantly different than a
hypothesized value to test if the mean
for two independent groups is
significantly different to test if the
mean for two dependent or paired groups
is significantly different for example
let's say you have to find out which
region spins the highest amount of money
on shopping it's impractical to ask
everyone in the different regions about
their shopping expenditure in this case
you can calculate the highest shopping
expenditure by collecting sample
observations from each region with the
help of the t-test you
check if the difference between the
regions are significant or a statistical
fluke ANOVA ANOVA is a generalized
version of the t-test and used when the
mean of the interval dependent variable
is different to the categorical
independent variable when we want to
check variance between two or more
groups we apply the ANOVA test for
example let's look at the same example
of the t-test example now you want to
check how much people in various regions
spend every month on shopping in this
case there are four groups namely east
west north and south with the help of
the ANOVA test you can check if the
difference between the regions is
significant or a statistical fluke chai
square Chi square is a statistical test
used to compare observed data with data
you would expect to obtain according to
a specific hypothesis let's understand
the chai square test through an example
you have a data set of male shoppers and
female shoppers let's say you need to
assess whether the probability of
females purchasing items of $500 or more
is significantly different from the
probability of males purchasing items of
$500 or more linear regression there are
two types of linear regression simple
linear regression and multiple linear
regression simple linear regression is
used when one wants to test how well a
variable predicts another variable
multiple linear regression allows one to
test how well multiple variables or
independent variables predict a variable
of interest when using multiple linear
regression we additionally assume the
predictor variables are independent for
example finding relationship between any
two variables say sales and profit is
called simple linear regression finding
relationship between any three variables
say sales cost telemarketing is called
multiple linear regression some of the
nonparametric tests are wilcoxon
rank-sum test and kruskal-wallis h test
wilcoxon rank-sum test
the wilcoxon signed-rank test is a
nonparametric statistical hypothesis
test used to compare two related samples
or matched samples to assess whether or
not their population mean ranks differ
in wilcoxon rank-sum test you can test
the null hypothesis on the basis of the
ranks of the observations kruskal-wallis
h test kruskal-wallis h test is a rank
based nonparametric test used to compare
independent samples of equal or
different sample sizes in this test you
can test the null hypothesis on the
basis of the ranks of the independent
samples the advantages of parametric
tests are as follows provide information
about the population in terms of
parameters and confidence intervals
easier to use in modeling analyzing and
for describing data with central
tendencies and data transformations
Express the relationship between two or
more variables don't need to convert
data into rank order to test the
disadvantages of parametric tests are as
follows only support normally
distributed data only applicable on
variables not attributes
let's now list the advantages and
disadvantages of nonparametric tests the
advantages of nonparametric tests are as
follows simple and easy to understand do
not involve population parameters and a
sampling Theory make fewer assumptions
provide results similar to parametric
procedures the disadvantages of
nonparametric tests are as follows not
as efficient as parametric tests
difficult to perform operations on large
samples manually
Hey want to become an expert in Big Data
then subscribe to the simply learned
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos sinnard up and get certified
in Big Data click here